welcome back for Donate Life month Dr
Richard Gilroy of Intermountain Health
the sponsors of this segment wants
people to remember that you can save a
life and live a life at the same time
through Oregon donation Rocky shares a
local story that exemplifies that
Amanda duquette Roberts is a chef and a
collector I've been in Las Vegas now for
15 years I work at the Wynn at Allegro
and I am a chef I like to collect
Oddities
anything strange is great for me she's
also a living kidney recipient I was
diagnosed with a kidney disorder when my
in my early 20s like 21 22. at the time
I was diagnosed I was already stage
three so one of the things about kidney
disease a lot of times you don't even
know you have it until it's already too
late I didn't find out about it until I
was in a car accident and they did an
x-ray of my back and they saw that my
kidneys were calcified
and the first nephrologist a diagnosed
me told me in about 20 years I would
need a kidney transplant
um in 2000 May of 2021 I was diagnosed
stage four and put on the transplant
list
um and when they first told me I was on
the transplant list they told me
um getting a deceased donor take
sometimes five to seven years for my
blood type
which
there's hundreds of thousands of people
waiting for transplants and you know
people die every day waiting a statistic
Intermountain Health is working to lower
Dr Richard Gilroy medical director of
Intermountain Health's liver transplant
program explains that Nevada is actually
underserved when it comes to
transplantation currently in Nevada
there are 640 people or they're about
awaiting an organ transplant in
situations one organ donor someone who
considers organ donation and family
members who support it in the era of a
tragedy usually for them they can save
as many as Nine Lives becoming a hero
like Amanda's sister-in-law Jones she
came to my rescue
um so she went and got tested but she
was the wrong blood type but through the
paired Exchange program we were able to
find a match that was probably even
better than my family would have been
what happens here is that
John who was the donor is the individual
who starts what's called a chain an
inner chain through the National Kidney
Foundation her organ can go to another
person in another place where her organ
is a match and an exchange another organ
from another individual within that
sequence can come back to her all that
came together to lead to this what I'd
say perfect change people tell me every
day how much better I look how much
healthier I look and I can feel it it's
just a it's really life-changing Amanda
in Intermountain Health are dedicated to
keeping communities informed and keeping
new kidneys healthy and kidney disease
kidney disease can come back and in her
case her kidney disease isn't something
she chose it is something that occurred
because of an immunologic injury meaning
that your body reacts a certain way
against you that could happen with the
donated kidney so we monitor for that
and we prevent it by keeping the
monitoring going and making adjustments
to the medications that you'll require
for life which is why gratitude and
giving back
main courses of Chef Amanda
isn't cute enough I've said Thank you a
million times it'll never be enough and
honestly the reason I'm doing this is to
try and pay it forward if even one
person finds out about the kidney
Exchange program through me and goes to
look to be a donor I felt like I've done
my part
thank you Intermountain Health for
sponsoring this segment for more
information you could head to
intermountainhealthcare.org donate life
there's more Las Vegas now just ahead we
will be